president trump gives his farewell
address the media go full meg ryan in
when harry met sally over joe biden
and president biden's early picks don't
inspire a lot of confidence i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
well the taxman is coming for you and
that means that you need to save money
in fact maybe that was one of your new
year's resolutions was to save money in
the next year well let's check that box
right now when your family switches to
pure talk from a t verizon or t-mobile
you could save over 800
a year that is real money every single
month right back in your pocket you
don't have to sacrifice coverage pure
talk is on the same network as one of
the big carriers
they're gonna charge you about half
that's right no gimmicks no fluff added
to the bills that is why puretalk is the
top rated
wireless company by consumer affairs and
how about this offer right now get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month if you go over
on data usage they're not going to
charge you for it so what exactly do you
have to lose
you are overspending with the cell phone
provider that you have right now instead
switch on over grab your mobile phones
i'll pound 250 say ben shapiro and when
you do
you say fifty percent off your first
month now pound two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro pure talk usa is
simply
smarter wireless again go on over to
puretalk usa by dialing pound two five
zero and saying my name ben shapiro to
save 50
off your first month and you're gonna be
saving hundreds of dollars a year over
at puretalk usa they are indeed
simply smarter wireless okay so today
is president trump's last day in office
he is leaving
around noon today or he left around noon
today depending on when you're listening
to this
and um and joe biden is slated to take
office around noon
eastern time he'll be sworn in slightly
before then that is when he is going to
be
giving his inauguration address and
we'll be covering that a little bit
later on
when he actually gives it but first
president trump has to leave
president trump gave a farewell address
last night and honestly listening to the
farewell address
it makes you sad for a couple of reasons
one what we're about to get from the
biden administration is not going to be
conducive to american liberty for all
the talk about the wonders of
of joe biden which we'll get to in just
a second and how he's going to bring the
country together
the reality is the next four years are
going to be a time in which many of your
core liberties are encroached upon
religious liberty will be encroached
upon freedom of speech will be
encroached upon freedom of association
will be encroached upon
all in the name of healing and unity
that is what we can expect
over the next four years i hope that
that is not so as with every president
every week in shul in in my synagogue we
pray for the government of the united
states including the president of the
united
who is holding the states i just pray
that joe biden doesn't do what his base
wants him to do which is to encroach
upon those core liberties that americans
hold dear so
seeing trump leave office and in some
ways he was a bulwark against a lot of
those encroachments
that's sad it's also sad to hear trump's
farewell address in the sense that
you hear what could have been had he
stayed on message
and this is something that that so many
of us said for years at a time
which was trump is giving us all this
good policy right he's giving us the
judges that we want he's giving us the
foreign policy
that we want he's giving us a booming
economy why can't he just stay
out of his own way why doesn't he just
stay on the teleprompter so
last night he gives his farewell address
and his farewell address is replete with
a bunch of statements that frankly
are great right he says a lot of things
here that i wish he had just said for
four years
and by the way if he had said that for
four years long then
he wouldn't be leaving the white house
with this with this sort of
aura of depression right if he he
probably wouldn't be leaving the white
house at all if he had stopped
with the extraneous nonsense that he was
doing
throughout his administration and had
just stuck to the fact that his
administration accomplished some pretty
fantastic fantastic things now here is
trump in his farewell address leading
off
as i conclude my term as the 45th
president of the united states i stand
before you
truly proud of what we have achieved
together
we did what we came here to do
and so much more this week we
inaugurate a new administration
and pray for its success in keeping
america safe
and prosperous we extend our best wishes
and we also want them to have luck a
very
important word okay so he still does not
mention joe biden's name there but
obviously he is talking about the
incoming
biden administration he then continues
and talks about american unity again
this is the message that i wish he had
been pressing forward for his entire
time in office yes he was taking
unbelievable slings and arrows like
no president in the modern history of
the united states i mean it was way
worse than what george w bush had to
take yes it is true that he was taking
an incoming fire
from people inside the executive branch
through the russia investigation and the
perversion of that investigation all of
that is true
it is also true that if he had presented
an optimistic face to the american
public during what was a boom time in
america before covet
it would have served him quite well here
is trump talking about american unity
we must never forget that while
americans will always have our
disagreements
we are a nation of incredible decent
faithful and peace-loving citizens
who all want our country to thrive and
flourish
and be very very successful and good
we are a truly magnificent nation
okay president trump continued along
these lines he talked about how
americans were horrified by the assault
on the capitol building and again this
is true i understand that for a lot of
the media for a lot of democrats
the idea here is that republicans were
totally fine with the assault on the
capitol building
that is not true the attempt to lump
everybody in with the capital rioters is
being
used as the pretext in order to encroach
on american liberties here was trump
talking
about the uh the horrible events of
january 6th
all americans were horrified by the
assault on our capital
political violence is an attack on
everything we cherish as americans
it can never be tolerated now more than
ever we must unify around our shared
values
and rise above the partisan ranker and
forge our
common destiny he uh he
again talked then about his his movement
he talked about the movement that he
had led uh and honest to god if you just
stayed on this message
the reason i'm frustrated here is
because again we're going to talk in a
second about what's about to hit the
united states in the form
of the biden administration and a lot of
people are saying oh return to normalcy
return
well in some ways it will be a return to
normalcy right you're not going to get
the
extraordinary bloviation you're not
going to get the crazy tweets you're not
going to get the daily news cycle that
revolves around something weird that
went through trump's head and then got
spilled out on twitter
that's not what you're going to get all
you're going to get in my
opinion and this is my prediction is
consistently bad policy that violates
your rights
right that's what you're going to get so
if that's the old normal the old normal
one that great i remember the obama
years
and i remember the gaslighting the media
put us through i remember the
establishment media
defending everything obama did even as
he encroached on their own liberties
obama jailed journalists obama was
engaging in foreign wars without
congressional supervision
and the media treated it like it was
nothing the media treated it like the
only scandal of the obama administration
was that he once wore tan suit so we're
gonna go right back to that we're just
gonna get the steady encroachment on
american liberty but we're not gonna get
at least the circus right the circus
won't be in town as much
but you know instead we'll get actual
policy that violates
your rights we'll get actual bad stuff
happening
in the united states much worse than
anything that trump did in terms of
policy
here is trump talking about his movement
together with millions of hard-working
patriots across this land
we built the greatest political movement
in the history of our country
we restored the principle that a nation
exists
to serve as citizens our agenda was not
about
right or left it wasn't about republican
or democrat but about the good of a
nation
and that means the whole nation okay
and um and then he spilled out a series
of his accomplishments
and by the way they are real
accomplishments right he talked about
the the income rising throughout the
nation in unprecedented ways in the
early years of the administration
it's like the stock market boom he
talked about how when the nation was hit
with a pandemic
operation warp speed helped contribute
to the development of vaccine inside
of months not years months nine months
and he talked about
border policy including agreements with
mexico guatemala honduras and el
salvador
to keep people in those countries as
they applied for asylum as well as
building wall he talked about america's
foreign policy and restoring a certain
level of
foreign policy leadership that was
completely lacking i mean it was barack
obama who suggested that america had to
lead from behind which is
a contradiction in terms you may have
noticed trump didn't do that trump may
have gone his own way on foreign policy
but all too often going his own way
meant actual good foreign policy
he talked about his his policy in the
middle east which led to historic peace
agreements
that never would have been possible
under a democratic administration
because the democrats believe
that the only way to solve the question
of peace in the middle east is to force
our only ally in the region israel into
concessions to terrorists
trump overturned that agenda and instead
he said you know what israel's not going
anywhere we're recognizing jerusalem as
israel's capital recognizing the golan
heights is israeli sovereign territory
and they're not going anywhere so you
may as well make peace with them if you
want to fend off
the iranian threat and it worked it
worked in extraordinary ways
right the abrahamic courts are a major
accomplishment a major diplomatic
accomplishment that if they had occurred
under any other president
would have undoubtedly won that
president a nobel peace prize
but most of all most of all what trump
should have stood for
what was the message that he was putting
out in some of his major addresses
whether it was his address in poland
with regard to western civilization or
his address at mount rushmore
with regards to american values right
the the notion that america ought to be
proud of its founding principles
when that leaves okay when that leaves
the white house
that is going to be a tragedy for the
country not trump leaving the white
house personally
right trump is just a person but what
replaces
trump the incoming biden administration
has already pledged itself
to the vision of the 1619 project which
is that america is a
is a horrible place filled with
brutality and racism
and that the only way that can be fixed
is the complete reimagining of the
relationship between individuals and
government
so this is why if you are a conservative
you think of this as a blown opportunity
you think of all the great things that
happened here in terms of policy and
then you think of this as a massive
blown opportunity
and the tragedy of a blown opportunity
is sometimes greater than the
than the tragedy of of inevitable fate
this was not inevitable
there was nothing here that was
inevitable it was not inevitable that
donald trump was going to lose to a
geriatric
dotard that was not that was not a thing
okay
trump's trump's loss is going to have
some pretty significant repercussions
for the rest of the country and by the
way losing those two senate seats in
georgia which he contributed to
is also going to have some pretty
serious repercussions for the united
states when you watch him talk as he did
in his farewell address
you think why couldn't we have had that
for four years why couldn't we have had
that
because if he had done that for four
years then he would have done it for
eight and we can get to more of what
trump had to say in his farewell address
in just
one second then we'll get to the
mainstream media just orgasming all over
themselves i mean it really is quite
disgusting
we'll get to that in just one moment
first i've been talking about expressvpn
on my show for months
why haven't you gotten a vpn yet you
need a vpn do you want big tech
looking over your shoulder particularly
big tech as pushed
into censorship by the democrats in
congress
and the media do you really want hackers
to be able to access your private
information online
you know this is why you need express a
vpn that's why i and thousands of my
patriotic listeners choose to secure our
online data by using expressvpn did you
believe that a vpn isn't for you because
you can use the internet just fine
without one well anytime you go online
your isp can see every site you're
visiting
if you're confused about how it works
expressvpn is an app for computers and
smartphones that encrypts your network
data reroutes it through a secure server
that means you can use the internet more
anonymously without having your activity
tracked
do you think vpns are complex only for
tech experts they are not okay i am
certainly not a tech expert
you can just download it it takes like a
couple of minutes you click a button you
are now protected it's that easy i trust
expressvpn to protect my online data
because they are rated number one by
cnet and wired
and they stand with my values now is the
time for you to take a stance
take back your privacy at expressvpn.com
get three extra months free
on a one year package again that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p
to get three extra months for free visit
expressvpn.com
ben right now okay so president trump
the message that he puts out in this
farewell address is the one that is
going to be lost amid
a democratic backlash to traditional
american values which they've been
pushing during the obama years they
continue to push it hard
today the basic idea of the democratic
party and the media
is that america is an awful place
founded on awful values yesterday
the white house had put out the 1776
report i talked about it briefly
on the show if the 1776 report was meant
as a rebuttal to the 6019 project
cnn reported not in an opinion piece
reported that it was racist
they said that the 1776 report which
basically just said the declaration is
good the constitution is good and
identity politics is bad was actually
racist so that is what is incoming here
hey trump in his farewell address
expresses the beliefs of i think
the vast majority of the american public
when he says no america is a wonderful
place
now here was trump talking about our
values is no nation
can thrive if you lose faith in your own
values
no nation can long thrive that loses
faith in its own values
history and heroes for these are the
very sources of our unity
and our vitality what has always allowed
america to prevail in triumph
over the great challenges of the past
has been an unyielding and unashamed
conviction
in the nobility of our country and its
unique purpose
in history we must never lose this
conviction
we must never forsake our belief in
america
okay but unfortunately many people have
lost their belief in america by the way
some of that applies on the right as
well as the left and if you storm the
capitol building because you believe
that america is so much on the brink
that there is no future for the country
unless you overthrow the democratic
process you have lost your faith in
america
okay so if you want to believe in
america then you actually have to
believe in its founding values and that
includes respect for its institutions
as well as a belief in the founding
values of liberty that are encoded in
the declaration of independence and the
constitution of the united states
and then trump continued along these
lines he talked about in a shared
national identity which of course
is completely contrary to the democratic
agenda which is to divvy everybody up
by race sex sexual orientation gender
identity and then to treat them
as separate members of groups and then
to redistribute the benefits of american
society
by group right here is trump cutting
against that
the key to national greatness lies in
sustaining and instilling our shared
national identity
that means focusing on what we have in
common
the heritage that we all share at the
center of this heritage
is also a robust belief in free
expression
free speech and open debate only if we
forget
who we are and how we got here could we
ever allow political censorship
and blacklisting to take place
in america it's not even thinkable
shutting down free and open debate
violates our core values
and most enduring traditions okay now
that is the next frontier of the battle
it is very obvious that the left the
democratic party
they are insistent that the first
amendment be curbed this is the message
from the media in the aftermath of the
capital riots is that your first
amendment rights have to be stopped
social media has to be used as a private
entity and abused as a private entity in
order to stop you
from exercising your first amendment
rights in fact we may have to rethink
the very concept of free speech in the
united states said cnn
yesterday okay so trump is not wrong
about all of this
the fact that that the fomenting of
untruths about the election
helped to create the climate for the
capital riots had is going to have
unforeseen effect
that are just grave for the future of
american liberty for sure
and so trump concludes on a very
dissonant note right because
it is indeed for conservatives a very
pessimistic time
if you are if you're a conservative it
is hard not to be disheartened today not
because
trump particularly is leaving the white
house although obviously if you see him
as a bulwark against the encroachments
of the left
that's a problem but mainly because they
look to the future and they see
democratic wins on the horizon they see
the renewal of the democratic cultural
tsunami
against them that happened during the
obama years except redoubled in strength
and power
they see all the institutions of the
united states run by members of the
hardcore left
or pliable corporate executives who are
willing to do their bidding
that is what they see so when trump says
when he concludes that he leaves joyful
and optimistic
a lot of conservatives are shaking their
heads today going um i'm not i'm not
sure why i should be joyful
and optimistic i'm not seeing exactly
what the future
holds that is good here okay and you
know what hold that feeling if you're a
conservative
hold that feeling and understand that
feeling it is not unjustified
but that is why the battle the
ideological battle the philosophical
battle
is not over it really is just beginning
because the very notion
that one man in the white house or even
a party in congress was gonna hold back
the cultural tide
when conservatives have abandoned that
or that if you just vote a guy into
power that he's gonna protect all of
your interests
it's an anti-american idea okay and it's
it's spread throughout
all sides of the american political
debate
right is this idea that if my man is in
the white house and everything is fine
and america's protected
i mean no you know what protects your
rights you know protects your rights
you your family your local community
the thing that protects all of america
is the social fabric that we build
between each other and an insistence
on not only our own rights but the
rights of others
so other institutions are going to have
to be built in the social sphere
because we are looking down the barrel
of social authoritarianism
not just coming from the biden
administration but from all again of
their institutional allies and
everywhere from the university to the
media to hollywood to social media
like all aspects of the american culture
all those guns have now been trained
on conservatives and we can see it
coming so when trump says that he's
joyful and optimistic
it just sounds dissonant it sounds
dissonant it sounds like a it sounds
like a
seventh yeah an octave is is uh
is you know in music an octave is is
non-dissonant the seventh
is that is that weird feeling that you
get when somebody is playing an a and
and uh and then almost an octave up uh
they are playing
uh a note that is one below the octave
right it's it
it sounds terrible it's actually called
the devil in music quick
music theory lesson there for you but it
sounds dissonant it doesn't sound
correct so here is trump
talking about joy as he leaves the oval
office and all conservatives across the
land shaking their heads
i go from this majestic place with a
loyal and joyful heart and optimistic
spirit
and a supreme confidence that for our
country
and for our children the best is yet
to come thank you and farewell
god bless you god bless the united
states
of america yeah well on his way out the
door
uh president trump issued a bunch of
pardons some of them are just
unjustifiable i mean frankly on just
foul he pardoned steve bannon
in the final hours of his presidency
okay whatever you think of steve bannon
and frankly i think that steve bannon is
a wet bag of garbage
lit aflame years ago uh
he's one of the worst people i
personally know steve bannon
the man was being tried for scamming
trump supporters that's what he was
being tried for
he was being tried for setting up a
private funding private funding effort
to quote unquote build the wall
and then he allegedly was taking that
money and lining his own pockets and out
of his cronies
again trump pardoned him on the way out
the door that's that's a that's an ugly
ugly thing to do okay well the big story
is not what trump does
as he leaves the big story is what comes
next because how are we going to fight
back against
all of this well the first thing
obviously that we have to fight is the
overwhelming power
of the media so trump for four long
years was battling with the media
and it was the the area of his
administration uh that was the most
unlike other administrations
it was also the area a lot of
conservatives resonated most too because
it's perfectly obvious the media are
just a propaganda arm for the democratic
party
and they are back in business baby for
them
i mean you can see them they're tweeting
each other as though they are graduating
high school
they're tweeting each other they're
signing each other's yearbooks like oh
my god we made it guys it was so hard
just the obnoxious 17 year old so so
hard we had to take we had to take like
pre-calculus together man remember that
time when we had to when we had to do a
test
that's how the media are treating each
other except they're patting their
themselves on the back for their actual
heroism under fire
and then they're like okay well i guess
we can go back to sleep it's exciting
stuff
i mean really exciting stuff the
establishment media massage parlor
and journalism outlet is back in session
so jim acosta
who is not a reporter he's an activist
who made a name off the fact that he
yelled at trump a lot
in the white house press room he he
tweeted out just a couple of guys
covering the white house on the last
full day of the trump administration
think we'll finally have time for that
drink now peter alexander guys we're
graduating high school
hope you had a good one i mean that
really is what this is
and then he like circles his picture 10
times he writes like a little a little
pink heart above his picture
say i love you i'll see you later and
then you never talk to him again
right that's it that is the that is the
jim acosta journalism that we have
become
accustomed to and and the amount of just
sycophantic worship that is now in play
for biden it's astonishing okay so i
sort of get it with obama i do
right like obama was the first black
president of the united states it was a
historic moment
there was this idea that we were all
going to move beyond the greatest
conflict in american history the racial
conflict that is riven american history
we were going to finally come together
as one because we had the first black
president and the media were just like
you know what we're not doing journalism
for the next eight years guys let's
party and go on vacation we are just
going to ignore everything that is
happening because this guy is so
historic okay this time
the person that they have decided to
worship fully praise
the person for whom they are jeffrey
tubening is a 78 year old
senile old corrupt politician from
delaware
that is the person for whom they are
doing this right so
we can dispense with the myth that the
media
were only doing it for obama they will
do it for any democrat any democrat who
takes office and is powerful
is now considered worthy of the
of the same treatment the new england
patriots owner received
at the flower garden and massage parlor
from the media the media honestly god
they're such i mean it's just
it's unbelievable
so i'm gonna i'm gonna show you the
whorishness of the media because again
here's the thing
if you are on the left and you're really
happy today totally understandable
you're on the left
if you proclaim that you're an objective
journalist that you are just a massage
parlor and in fact you're performing
prostitution out of the back it's a
little bit different
hey i'm conservative that means that i
get to be upset when a democrat takes
office
and i will be happy if republican takes
office and i try to be
above simple republican democrat and
actually go to conservative principle
right i'm pretty obvious about what i do
i'm pretty obvious about who i am but
seeing jim acosta treating this thing
like
well guys we finally did it yeah i know
you finally did it glad to see that you
finally accomplished what you had sought
all along which was to make sure that a
democrat gets elected in the next
election
right that is the exact okay so i'm
going to show you the media shift
because the media flipped
boom they went from the country is a
flame
all will die hell fire
i'm here for your like put on a
holocaust cloak from princess bride
getting rolled forward like andre the
giant warning everybody that we're all
gonna die
right and then they flip on a dime and
suddenly it's my little ponies
suddenly it's rainbow sparkle yes my
daughter watches my little ponies
hey and it's and it's it's applejack
right running through the meadows
that the flip in time is astonishing and
it is perfectly clarifying as far as
who these people are and the answer is
they are just activists they are just
activists
and here's the thing if you want to be
an activist be an activist if you want
to be a journalist and pretend to be
objective
don't be a can we get to this in
just one second first
let us talk about defending your rights
and defending yourself and your family
when the founders wrote the constitution
the first thing they did was make sacred
the rights of the individual to share
their ideas without limitation by their
government the second thing they did
was secure the rights of individuals to
protect that speech and their lives with
force
if necessary owning a rifle is a heavy
responsibility and building rifles is no
different
bravo company manufacturing bcm for
short builds a professional-grade
product built to combat standards
this is because bcm believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every american regardless of whether
they're a private citizen or a
professional
the people at bcm assume when a rifle
leaves their shop it will be used in a
life or death situation
by a responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier
overseas i personally take gun ownership
incredibly seriously abide by the law
know what you are doing train with your
guns know how to use them in case god
forbid you need to use it to protect
your life
and the people at bcm feel the exact
same way they make incredible incredible
products
to learn more about bravo company
manufacturing head on over to
bravocompanymfg.com you can discover
more about their products special offers
upcoming news that is
bravocompanymfg.com now by the way would
be a good time if you've not invested in
a rifle do it before
joe biden prevents you from being able
to do it if you need more convincing
find out even more about bcm and the
awesome people who make their products
at youtube.com
bravo company usa that is
bravocompanymfg.com okay so
i mean the the whorishness of the media
knows no bounds it is
astonishing i'm just going to read you a
series of headlines these headlines have
been threaded over twitter by david
harsanyi who writes for national review
and new york post it is these are pretty
amazing okay here we go you ready
this one uh gotta love this one all the
times joe biden's love for ice cream
melted our hearts how about this one
from cnn politics
joe biden and kamal harris drop a
playlist for your inauguration watch
party
wow wow and then there was that vogue
cover remember there's a vo cover of
kamala harris and there was an entire
debate in the media over whether it was
too disrespectful of kamal harris
because i remember those sorts of
debates over donald trump were the uh
were the covers of donald trump
as like a pin cushion were those
respectful but we got kamala harris
in this kind of weird pose standing in
front of a
pink curtain wearing her converse and
this is considered disrespectful even
though it literally says on the cover of
vogue
by the people for the people the united
states of fashion
madam vice president kamala harris and
the new america
journalisming up the wazoo then we had
of course jane paulie
remember sitting down with kamala harris
and um and looking all weird because she
had to mirror
the awkward pathological laughter that
kamala harris
spews from her face every time she uh
she says something weird
okay the washington post headline today
most people know her as jill biden
but to some she is dr b the
compassionate
and challenging educator who went the
extra mile
wow wow incredible
by the way stephen colbert yeah last
night cut an entire music video
about how melania trump is the worst
person in the world
she didn't do anything she was just
there for four years but she's michelle
obama the greatest hillary clinton the
greatest
melania just horrifying horrifying glenn
kessler of the washington post
quote get ready for reality grounded
white house press briefings yes yes i
remember all those reality grounded
white house press briefings where jay
carney and chen sackey just lied
consistently to you and robert gibbs
they just lied over and over and over to
you but you guys didn't care
because you were too busy performing
unspeakable acts upon the administration
um also this is one of my favorites
lauren wolfe is an editor at the new
york times she deleted this tweet
okay she deleted the sweet because it
was even too awkward for her
she tweeted out a picture of of
president-elect biden arriving at joint
base andrews
and then above it she wrote biden
landing at joyce joint base andrews now
i have chills
wow i'll have what she's having exciting
stuff
the washington post in fashion joe biden
and kamal harris display
their common ground amazing
of a journalist named shimon procopex
let the healing begin
we have needed this needed a senile old
man running the government
and encroaching upon our fundamental
right we needed it
it just solid stuff james homan another
journalist
he's the healer in chief the healer in
chief that's his job don't you
understand
he's like a shamanistic healer who can
heal him he lays on hands
and america is healed the very moment
that joe biden takes office
all of our all of our wounds are bound
all of the negativity and toxicity of
our politics is ended
also we're going to need some of your
first amendment just a little bit of it
like just the part where you say you
don't agree
we're going to need that part over at
politico biden is about to give the most
important inaugural speech since lincoln
is he though since lincoln okay well i
hope that he can stumble
i hope he can stumble his way through it
without trump and i'm assuming for sure
that'll be that'll be exciting
the flip in time is pretty amazing david
chalian over at cnn i think
this may be the best clip so this is cnn
last night and the guy can't control
himself he
just cannot control himself so they show
this uh
on screen some video from the national
mall
okay and it shows the from the
washington mall and it shows
the uh the they've planted several
hundred thousand flags
out there to signify the deaths from
covet because obviously they can't have
lots of people
on on them all right now for both safety
reasons and also because we are in the
middle of a pandemic still
and they they're shining these bright
lights up into the sky
uh and it's very dramatic right it's
very dramatic footage
and david chalian cannot help himself he
can't help himself
he goes to work and here he is working
both himself and the biden
administration
those lights that are that are just
shooting out from the lincoln memorial
along the reflecting pool i look it's
like almost
extensions of joe biden's arms embracing
america it was a moment where the new
president came to town
and sort of convened the country in this
moment of remembrance
outstretching his arms and contrast that
with that video you just saw
of a disgraced president on his way out
at his lowest point
in his presidency wow i mean it's like
he's like he's giving us a big hug and
then awkwardly stroking our hair and
sniffing us
it's just like that like it's like
lights shooting out that wasn't the only
thing shooting out in this particular
clip
amazing amazing stuff david like arms
embraces i don't want the government
embracing me okay
the government should stay far away from
me so last night i had some dinner with
some folks
and a friend was talking about how he
really likes the pomp and circumstance
of
inaugurations no matter who's being
inaugurated and
i said i agree that the exiting
president should go to the inauguration
okay trump should go to biden's
inauguration
obama did it for trump didn't matter
they hated each other right that is a
thing that should happen because it does
signify the peaceful transfer power it
is wrong for trump not to do that
however i generally hate pomp and
circumstance with regard to the
presidency despise it i despise it
because it is monarchic
and it is ridiculous i hate it with
regard to the state of the union i've
been perfectly consistent on this
for years and years and years i think
that the president is basically a
plumber i think they should swear him in
the back of a car and then he should go
do some plumbing
i i don't think he's an important person
i don't think that the presidency of the
united states should be treated
as though he is an emperor a god emperor
on earth embracing us with his arms
okay that sort of idolatous crap is bad
for the country but the media
love it they are into it and again they
can't help themselves today
honestly what's i think what's most
galling to conservatives is not even
biden taking office
it's the fact that we are now guaranteed
four years of gaslighting where the
objective journalists
decide that journalism consists mostly
of of performing favors uh of an
unspeakable type
on the biden administration and and and
then declaring themselves objective
in all of their facets right after four
years of reporting every sniff of a
rumor
unsourced or sourced inside the trump
administration we'll go back to the good
old days of talking about how wonderful
barack obama's fashion sense is and how
he could have played in the nba or
something
right it'll be really really exciting
stuff okay we're gonna get to more of
the media's worship
abide and then we'll get to what exactly
biden is planning because
it's not good for the country guys it
ain't good again i'm praying for the
incoming administration just as i prayed
for the trump administration we
literally do that every sabbath in my
synagogue
that doesn't mean i expect that he's
going to do good things in fact i expect
he's going to do things that are deeply
damaging to core american liberties
get some more of this in just one second
first let us talk about the time piece
that you wear so
perhaps you're counting the hours of
this administration
perhaps you need a watch to help you
count those hours as they
tick away well if you need a watch it's
going to work and it's also going to
look good what you really need
is a vincero you're not going to spend a
fortune on a vincero watch vincero
is dedicated to the craft they put the
time and effort into crafting timepieces
so you can wear them day after day right
here look at this this is a really nice
timepiece from vincero and it is not
going to cost you
a fortune i've been working with vincero
for a couple of years now they become
one of my favorite brands the guys know
just how important it is to look and
feel your best
and they are here to help keep you
motivated throughout 2021
if you're looking to upgrade your look
don't waste money on any other
watch brand out there instead head on
over to vincerowatches.com check out
my favorite picks take advantage of my
special discount while you shop it's
important to shop right now we've got a
brand new limited edition release for
the new year
that's going to sell out really fast
ventura understands the frustrations of
online shopping they get it that's why
they're going to make it super easy for
you with the new year they are now
offering a five
year warranty and a 365 day return
policy some of the best promises in the
business
they have over twenty six thousand five
star views they make a great gift i've
gotten ventura watches for many members
of my family
most importantly it supports the show
when you purchase from vincero so go
shop there right now
v-i-n-c-e-r-o watches dot com slash
shapiro again that's vincero watches
v-i-n-c-e-r-o watches dot com
slash shapiro go to that link pick out
your favorite watch get a great discount
right now alrighty so before we get to
the rest of the
media who just cannot help themselves
and again they're moving along two lines
one is joe biden is the greatest thing
that has ever happened in the history of
the united states which is
insane and second is it's time for
revenge
right we all know where this is going
and then we'll get to actually what
biden is planning before we get to any
of that
last thursday was a big day for the
daily wire because we are going to fight
in the culture okay and the way we're
going to fight in the culture is we're
going to get competitive in the culture
we're not just going to tear down the
culture
made by the left we are going to make
our own culture we have made
our first feature film run hide fight is
an excellent movie it's got like 98
on rotten tomatoes from viewers and like
22 from critics which is
exactly what you would predict we make
stuff you love and the critics hate if
you missed it head on over to daily wire
where you can stream run hide fight on
demand from our website
mobile or streaming apps on apple tv and
roku if you're not a member yet use
promo code rhf to get 25
off that is rhf for 25 off
please be aware the film isn't political
it is intense it is for mature
audiences only so it's not for the
kiddos it stars isabelle may thomas jane
and rona mitchell
run hide fight follows zoe hull who's a
17 year old girl who's just trying to
get through
the last few weeks of high school and
then she finds herself in the middle of
a school shooting
while also trying to navigate the recent
death of her mother it's a great movie
okay and by the way if you saw the movie
and you liked it leave a review over
rotten tomatoes leave a review anywhere
else because we need to fight back in
the culture we're excited to bring you
great stories that are going to not spit
on your values
right now you get 25 off at
dailywire.com to become a member
when you use promo code rhf for run hide
fight go watch the movie
today get a membership in order to do so
dailywire.com you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
okay so now we're going to get the
god-like worship of joe biden again a
senile daughter who can barely hold it
together
they're going to treat him the exact
same way they treated obama which
explains that it really was never about
obama it was just about the media
who are all democratic voters like
almost universally democratic voters
who not only hate trump but hate
republicans more generally the
washington post editorial board
democracy dies in darkness gang
literally their words in their first
words in their editorial today is
well we made it i mean you made it was
there any threat to shut down the
washington post
you made it oh my god just by the skin
of our teeth we made it
some 1461 days after donald trump took
office as president he must leave it
having been defeated for re-election
last november third by joseph r biden
who will be sworn in as the 46th
president at noon on wednesday
this is a momentous occasion oh my gosh
okay so that is the washington post
journalism all over the place
oh also it was very important uh we now
have a report from the new york times
this is breaking news
here's the breaking news the breaking
news is that joe and jill biden
have morning negotiations over who rides
the peloton bike first
holy unreal
oh they've broken the story
amazing how is that possible according
to cheryl
g stolberg reporting for the new york
times biden has a peloton bike that
raises issues
at the white house it doesn't exactly
comport with his regular joe from
scranton persona but beyond the policies
of it the bike
could present cyber security risks wow
wow and again he and joe biden they have
to negotiate see this just shows he's a
real diplomat right he has to negotiate
with his wife over the peloton
by the way if trump had ever bought
melania a peloton would be what a sexist
is for buying his wife a peloton right
that's the way that works also if that
was not enough for you the style section
of the washington post
has a fascinating article on doug imhoff
kamala harris's husband
wow can't wait to hear about doug emhoff
why i hadn't heard of until five seconds
ago
a truly important figure in american
politics who's never been elected to
anything
and happens to be married to kamal
harris i remember when we had all of
those
those absolutely sycophantic pieces
about mike pence's wife remember that
yeah no you don't oh yeah that's right
because they didn't exist
so all of this is very very exciting
stuff
eddie glaude from msnbc puts the final
cap on this
he compares joe biden to god i mean he
literally paraphrases
these psalms from the bible to describe
joseph r
biden a corrupt old politician who has
been in politics
since he was 29 years old at the federal
level here is eddie glaude
literally comparing joe biden of all
human beings
to god just listening to the words and
the song
and singing the lights president-elect
joe biden and vice president harris
pulled the grief and regret
out of the privacy of our hearts if just
for a moment so that we all could share
it
oh what a first step what a beautiful
step so i'm i'm gonna you know i'm
reminded of the psalmist
you know he heals the brokenhearted and
binds up their wounds
my god okay so
um the four years of this guys four
years this is why you should come
subscribe to daily wire because
at least we are going to cover that like
there will be things happening and we
will cover them at daily wire
but you can guarantee that in the
mainstream establishment media
basically it's just going to be why
republicans keep pouncing why do they
keep pouncing pounce pounce pounds
every time biden does something truly
crappy it'll be wow look at those
republicans pouncing and spoiling all
the unity there was unity guys
and the unity meant shut the hell up
he's speaking of which
i mean they're pretty clear about this
so eddie glad right he wants to buying
up the nation's wounds right that same
guy
who was a second ago talking about
binding the nation's wounds and
healing the rift and then he's like you
know what there are 400 000 dead people
because of the trump supporters
a thing he actually said on msnbc same
day
yesterday yes i trust our members of the
media to to truly take seriously the
concerns of all americans they just want
to bind up our wounds
by calling you a person responsible for
hundreds of thousands of deaths here is
here's eddie cloud
it's easy for us to place
all of the blame on donald trump he
makes it easy for us
you know he does but there were 75
74 plus million people
who voted for him selfishness
greed you know they run rampant across
the land
oh that sounds like some some real wound
binding right there
right there yeah that's that's probably
the psalmist was talking about
it was it was about like binding up the
nation's wounds by calling all the
people who disagree with you
uh selfish and greedy and responsible in
order to understand what you're saying
you have to see the picture
which is a picture of all of these flags
on the mall that are supposed to
represent the 400 000 kova deaths
so you're responsible for that if you
voted for trump exciting exciting stuff
also
it'll be wonderful to hear the history
of this period written
by political grifters like steve schmidt
and the guy who used to be part of the
mccain
campaign and then decided that he'd be
part of the lincoln project he's going
to write the history says
he says on msnbc
the winners write history and they're
the losers
the shame of the people around trump who
have participated in the shaping of the
great american catastrophe
over the last four years will be held to
account
will be held to account by the judgment
of history
by the judgment of decent americans
they'll be held to account by corporate
america as they look for jobs
by corporate america as they seek
donations
they will not write their history we
will write their history
and their shame will last forever
they're shameless says steve schmidt by
the way uh just a quick note one of the
co-founders of the lincoln project
i just dropped out because it turned out
that he was a dm'ing
young men for um sexual purposes so yeah
they're ashamed but our shame is gonna
last forever everybody everybody who
supported any elements of the trump
agenda the shame will last forever okay
so
this brings us to what they will be
covering for isn't this exciting
so what exactly will they be covering
for your entire establishment media who
have decided that
the age of light has reached us what
would they be covering for
a bunch of truly unbelievably bad policy
that is what they will be covering for
and it begins
today are you excited here we go cause
you know what they got rid of the bad
orange man who's really bad in orange
and also even if he is really bad and
authoritarian
in his sort of intent we got rid of all
of the conservative policy so
now we can finally untrammeled move
forward toward a
more racially polarized a more woke
society
that dispenses with these little things
like your rights right we can move
toward that at full speed
ahead it is so exciting it is so
exciting
according to felix salmon over at axios
led by incoming treasury secretary janet
yellen the economic policy team has
signaled it will be the first
administration
ever to construct economic policy around
issues like race
gender equality and climate change
rather than traditional indicators like
gross domestic product or deficit ratios
amazing i'm so excited about this guys
the treasury department the economy of
the united states will not be
constructed
around what provides the most prosperity
to the most people instead
it will be it will be designed around
notions that america
is systemically racist and unjust and we
can just redistribute
and regulate the economy so as to
achieve equal outcome without any worry
about what the inputs to the economy are
isn't that super exciting we can divide
each other by race
and then by sex and like sexual
orientation and everything and then it
can reorient the entire economic policy
of the united states
in order to meet pre-examined quotas
with regard to each one of those groups
all we have to do is violate some of
your economic and free association and
liberty rights that's all we have to do
just a little thing that's all we have
to do and the media is there for it man
they are so excited
about all of this super exciting stuff
that is according to axios today
also biden has now announced the 17
executive actions he's going to sign in
this afternoon in the oval office yay
so what are some of these magical
magical things
that he is going to be doing so number
one he's gonna was literally number one
he's gonna stop the border wall
construction okay first of all if that
was like your top pro
like that's purely symbolic of course
right because the reality is
having a border wall kind of a good
thing but he's like you stop that right
now we have to spend trillions of
dollars
on redistributive purposes we can't be
spending some money on like a wall to
stop people from coming across the
border illegally stop that right now now
if that had not been trump's top
priority would he be doing that of
course not
he's going to quote and the muslim
travel ban there is no muslim travel ban
it does not exist
there is a travel ban against a variety
of countries which includes some muslim
countries and some non-muslim countries
okay he's going to rejoin the paris
climate agreement
wow so that paris climate agreement
which achieves nothing
zero things does it achieve it is a
completely symbolic act
that is designed in order to cuddle
political opponents into silence that is
what the paris climate accord does
the vast majority of countries that have
signed on to the paris climate accords
are not even attempting to meet their
quotas
the united states has no plan in order
to achieve what joe biden wants to
achieve and even if the united states
were to meet its quotas under the paris
climate accords
it would not lower the global temp uh
temperature over the course of the next
century
more than a minute degree these are all
well-established realities
but we're joining the paris climate
accords good stuff guys also we're going
to end the keystone xl pipeline
and revoke oil and gas development at
national wildlife monuments so that's
good news we're going to make ourselves
more dependent on foreign oil again so
that's that's excellent
also we're going to count you
non-citizens in the u.s census
okay so one of the things that trump had
pushed was we're not gonna count illegal
immigrants in the u.s census
because we use the u.s census for
apportionment purposes and we should not
apportion congressional seats
based on how many people who literally
should not be in the country
are in particular areas and by's like no
you know what i know where all those
people live and they tend to live in
blue areas and we need more
congressional seats appointed
a portion for those particular areas
we're rejoining the who
that's exciting so we left the who
because the who is a crap
sandwich of an organization that
basically is a propaganda outlet for the
chinese
but we're rejoining it because trump
left it that's literally the only reason
to rejoin it
also he's starting the 100 days masking
challenge ooh
do we get like those physical fitness
badges like i remember when i was in
elementary school
and if you basically didn't keel over in
fourth grade then they gave you like a
presidential
physical fitness award it was super
exciting
and it went directly in the garbage
because it meant nothing so we're gonna
have the 100 day
masking challenge because you know what
people aren't asking except for you know
the 80 plus percentage of people who say
they're asking
in the united states so yep um that'll
be good
he's going to push pause on student loan
payments until september 30th
he's going to defend the dreamers
program for undocumented young americans
he's going to continue to do the
unconstitutional thing of just
declining to prosecute people as he
ought under the law
he's going to change trump's arrest
priorities for immigration and customs
enforcement
he's going to restructure the federal
government coordination to the covenant
19 pandemic but he doesn't explain how
and here we go he this is the best part
you ready actions to advance
racial equity through the federal
government so
welcome back to critical race theory
gang because remember trump said no
critical race theory in the federal
government we're not going to do any of
those things
and brian's like nope we're putting all
that back in so you get to learn about
how whiteness dominates america's
systems of power
and how you are responsible you are a
white person and it doesn't matter if
you're a black person who agreed
in any element with trump this means
that you are also white you're a
multi-racial white person
very exciting stuff he's going to revoke
trump's quote-unquote harmful 1776
commission
so instead he's just going to reflect
the 1619 bull crap promoted by the new
york times america's evil
america's terrible all this is in the
name of healing guys do you feel the
healing can you feel the warmth
can you feel it so much healing
happening right now
he's going to strengthen quote workplace
discrimination protections based on
sexual orientation
and gender identity which effectively
means that the federal government is now
going to be telling you
that if you are a waiter at a if you are
a
waitress at a hooters and you decide
that you are a man tomorrow you should
remain a waitress at the hooters
so that's exciting stuff also
we are going to be freezing all
last-minute trump administration
regulatory actions
and they're going to formulate executive
branch ethics doctrines because that's
always worked
usually when members of the government
including the trump administration
formulate ethics doctrines
they then follow through with them by
you know completely ignoring them
so all of this is exciting stuff among
the people who
biden will be appointing also some of
the best and the brightest so for
example
joe biden has now selected as assistant
health secretary
rachel levine the only important thing
about this human being is that this
person is transgender
that's according to the washington post
headline this is true here is the
washington post headline now you might
think to yourself as assistant health
secretary wouldn't you want like the
accomplishment in the title
like what did this person do to become
assistant health secretary here's the
title biden selects transgender doctor
rachel levine as assistant health
secretary
well i mean i know that when i go to the
doctor the first thing i need is a
person
who believes they're a member of the
wrong sex that's that's the first thing
i look for
rachel levine by the way is a human
being who shipped covet-positive
patients
back into nursing homes as the secretary
of health and human services
in pennsylvania and then took this
person's mother
out of the nursing homes in order that
that person would not be infected and
die
so that might be like the headline right
and if the media were doing their job
that would be like the top of the story
right you know that if trump had
appointed this person that would be the
top of the story but because this person
checks the intersectional box
well magic so here's the case on rachel
levine
cons killed a bunch of people in nursing
homes by shipping covered positive
patients
back into the nursing homes pros is a
man who believes he is a woman
strong case being made here huge huge
stuff
so listen i understand all the people
who are ready for the circus to end
i understand all the people who are like
you know what this last four years was
crazy and wild and feels like a fever
dream
i get it just understand that all of
your peace and healing and unity
in reality it comes along with much a
really really bad policy that is
actually going to affect how you live in
the united states on a daily basis
not just what irritating things people
tweet about on twitter
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with one additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show michael is back on air
after the recent birth of his brand new
baby boy although i'll be honest with
you i don't even know
how michael knows that that is a brand
new baby boy that child has not decided
his gender and will not do so for the
next 18 years
michael will be talking about some of
the good things coming from mitt romney
in the confirmation hearings yesterday
be sure to catch up with him with
today's episode which is available
right this very instant i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling production
manager pavel wydowsky
our associate producers are rebecca
doyle and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright 2021 president trump leaves
office
joe biden looks to give amnesty to 11
million illegal aliens and joe biden's
nominations to key posts are nuttier
than a fruitcake check it out on the
michael knowles show
you